marnik John it is October 3rd it is
Wednesday October 3rd so I'm sorry
this house is giddy with the Yeti
but it's dedicated the Yeti isn't your
birthday
Africa that's Yeti
song is about a woman scorned baby coos
your eyes
in you do dusty I realize but you're in
a lot of pain and I'll call it just
I never wanted it this way please don't
cry
you
maybe I sold your dog on
we both knew that we had bills to pay it
was either him for my playstation 2
which doesn't even eat food and will
never ever be on a duvet one day I came
home and that dog had his game to keep
forsook his poem and instead he ate
everything I own from the couch to the
drapes I called you on the phone instead
of selling it on eBay
we don't know that we've got bills to
pay he peed on season two of deep space
nine that's crossing the line
unlisting the auction today
in a box with some styrofoam peanuts a
bag and cable and a couple of milk balls
the guy online paper overnight shipping
so the very next day he wasn't
please don't cry oh please do
they please don't cry
damnit
stop crying
ah he's an ugly dog like a bomber
walking buzzing he poops constantly more
than any other dog but we won't have to
worry about any more because babe listen
to
yeah I sold them on eBay we don't know
that we've got bills to pay I got $150
for that let me go over my fork and I
know there'll be hell to pay
yeah we have bills to pay so I sold her
got on eBay I told her you've got to
understand
yeah it's in funny absolutely Kurdistan
yeah you could sit but he absolutely
couldn't stand
okay that was wrong song so I have to go
John tomorrow when I see you talk about
having us project